... the first Fantastic Four movie,
and I think you guys will agree with
me, that dared to ask the question,
what would the Thing look like if he didn't
wear pants the whole time? And it answered.
Tom, Nina, what upcoming Marvel
release will have the biggest impact
on the MCU and why?
Nina, I defer to you.
Thank you, sir. I went through a few things here
because in terms of the reveal in Falcon and the
Winter Soldier of Julia Louis-Dreyfus' character,
the Contessa, there are possibilities for her.
She was originally supposed to appear
in Black Widow. Is that correct?
That is my understanding, yeah.
That was supposed to be her MCU debut,
and then this came first because of the pandemic.
Right. Everything had to get delayed.
And so, I think that there's a lot of potential
with such a huge star to have some really good
crossover with that. But ultimately, the one
I hope has the most impact is actually Thor:
Love and Thunder because we're going to get to
see the return of Natalie Portman to the MCU.
And her character was really pretty dull
in the first two Thor movies, but clearly,
she has enough faith in Taika Waititi to
come back and pick that role back up.
But she's also going to be female Thor.
So I'm really hoping that that has
long running ramifications in the entire MCU. I
mean, obviously, there's the real-world logistics
of does Natalie Portman want to commit
like 10 years of her life or something to
the universe? Because Robert Downey Jr. and Chris
Evans were getting weary of it. There were reports
way before they did leave the franchise that they
wanted to. I guess that remains to be seen, but
I'm really hoping that her female Thor is huge in
the MCU. I mean, literally and figuratively huge.
Literally huge.
I want her to just
grow it into a colossus and to kick Thor-
Gigantic.
... out.
That is what she's best known for.
Yes, Natalie Portman, notably huge person.
Her imposing frame.
Yeah.
I'm really looking forward to that movie. I
think it's going to be really cool. I think
that it'll be interesting to see. Yeah, you're
right. The main Thor is going off into space
with the Guardians of the Galaxy. And so,
we're going to have this new Thor. Is she
going to show up in Avengers 5? Is she going to
show up in other projects? Is there going to be
a long-term plan for Natalie Portman
in this MCU now that she's back and
more interested in participating?
I think that that's a really good
point. I think that's interesting.
Yeah. I'm really excited to see where this goes.
Tom.
Hey.
What do you think? What is going to be the
most impactful project that Marvel is going
to be putting out that's going to have the
biggest impact on an MCU going forward?
When we say impact, what do we mean? We mean
it's going to change the franchise, right?
Long lasting ramifications
in some way, shape or form.
That's exactly what I'm talking about, Brian. I
love to hear the one on the same page. Yes, no,
I agree. And I think that the only way to the
franchise in any meaningful way is to do what?
Is to expand it. More characters, we need to
bring in more characters that people love,
specifically recognizable characters. That's why
I think the Fantastic Four is going to be the
biggest and most impactful addition to
the MCU for the next several years.
Okay. Tell us why.
It all goes back to 2015.
You remember the Josh Trank Fantastic Four movie?
Mm-hmm.
I try not to. Yeah.
I don't like your attitude, Nina.
There were parts of it that were good.
I don't like your attitude.
The movie is overall not good at all.
No.
It was the first
Fantastic Four movie, and I think you guys will
agree with me that dared to ask the question,
what would the Thing look like if he didn't
wear pants the whole time?And it answered. It
answered for an hour and I want to say 27 minutes,
whatever the cutoff is for being an actual movie
in terms of runtime, it answered that question.
In 2013, Josh Trank's Fantastic Four movie, and
see if you follow me here, included a promotional
tie-in with the Denny's chain of restaurants,
in which they introduced a new menu called
appropriately, the Slamtastic 4. This included
meals like the Human Torch Skillet, the
Thing Burger and the Dr. Doom Lava Cake.
Let's assume that this is canon. Let's assume
that the menu is carrying over into the MCU.
That would mean that Denny's is now part of
the MCU. And do you know who loves Denny's?
Tim Allen from the first Santa Claus movie. That
would bring in, not just Santa Claus himself,
but also, I'm failing to remember the name of the
actor, the guy from Numbers. What was his name?
David Krumholtz.
David Krumholtz. We could
bring David Krumholtz into to the MCU. How would
that not be the biggest day of all of our lives?
I would be into that. I'm a big
fan of David Krumholtz and his-
I've never thought about David Krumholtz's path
to the MCU, but it's very clear to me now.
Now that we see it, we can't unsee it.
No.
Guys, I just bought a corporate. It's
not ready yet, but I'm going to hang it
up. I'm going to have so many visual aids
ready for the next time that we do this.
Oh man. As long as it says Pepe
Silvia on it, then we're good to go.
Can we back up a second though?
Yeah.
And seriously ask, would anyone here actually
eat something called a Thing Burger?
Nobody did, Brian.
No.
A Thing Burger. That's your-
Nobody that
didn't go to public school and get hot lunch
ate anything that was called a Thing Burger.
Imagine being in the room with the marketers
and say, "Okay, we've got this great
Fantastic Four tie-in with Denny's."
We've got the Doom Lava Cake,
the Human Torch Skillet.
Dr. Doom Lava Cake, Human Torch Skillet.
Let me tell you what we got right now.
The piece de resistance.
We got a sandwich that looks like a rock.
And we call it-
at just the right temperature.
We call it a Thing Burger.
Doesn't that sound good?
I'm hungry.
Wow. Wow. Okay.
These are facts. Brian, what do you think?
Thank you for asking, Tom. I should have
waited, but I didn't because I'm so excited.
I wouldn't ask you.
Because my pick comes much sooner than Fantastic
Four, but it is tied to the Fantastic Four. And it
is Ant-Man 3: Quantumania directed by Peyton Reed.
Here's why I think that Ant-Man 3 is going to be
the most impactful movie for the MCU going forward
for the foreseeable future. In Ant-Man
and the Wasp, the second Ant-Man movie,
we find out that Ant-Man is going to go quantum.
The original Ant-Man is going to go quantum,
rescue the original Wasp from the quantum realm
and do all kinds of shenanigans that way.
Then Paul Rudd's Scott Lang gets trapped in
the quantum realm at the end of that movie
and comes back to life in Avengers:
Endgame. He pops out of the van, Ant-Van.
And using his knowledge and technology of the
quantum realm is able to help the Avengers pull
off the time heist to get the infinity stones to
bring back everybody. I contend that Ant-Man 3
will similarly explore the quantum realm
and open up the Marvel multi-verse,
because if you can go through time through the
quantum realm, you can also probably go through
different dimensions and explore different realms
and bring in characters like the Fantastic Four.
Here's another thought I had. The Fantastic Four
is one of the oldest groups of Marvel superheroes
outside of Captain America and Human Torch and a
few others like Namor who haven't been introduced
yet. Fantastic Four's whole thing-
The Marvel age of comics.
Exactly, is exploring realms outside of
our knowledge. What if you have a story
in which at the end of Ant-Man, he comes into
contact with the Fantastic Four and they say,
"Finally, we're back. You've freed us from our
adventure in dimension Z," or whatever. And then
everyone's like, we've never heard of you. What?
And then you get this pre-established bunch
of characters that we get to be introduced to
because they've been lost and they're introduced.
And then you can play with all kinds
of things where, because they left,
their history was erased and time started over. I
don't know. You could do something, but there is a
way to connect the whole Marvel multi-verse, maybe
even bring in some of those former cast members
from those old Fantastic Four movies, maybe make
them canon again. Maybe don't make them canon
and do something different, but you can still
introduce all these great properties that way.
That's what I kind of theorized they were going to
do in WandaVision and then they didn't. They were
going to somehow bring in the multi-verse. That's
how I think that Ant-Man 3 is going to be the
most influential one. They're going to be the ones
that introduce the Fantastic Four and the X-Men.
I love that. It's perfect because I feel
like Ant-Man is this very unassuming part
of the MCU. I did not see Ant-Man and the Wasp
when it was originally released. I kind of was
like, eh, whatever, and I skipped it. And then a
friend of mine who loves all things Marvel, when
I told him that he was like, "Oh my God. So you
didn't see the credit scene. Infinity war makes
no sense." Or I guess Endgame made less sense
because I had not yet seen that credit scene.
And so, it's kind of under the radar where
you're like, Ant-Man, is that important?
He's tiny. But then it holds the key
like you're saying to the entire thing.
Tiny but mighty.
True. It unlocks like so much. I think you're
onto something really cool here.
I think I am, too. Thank you, Nina.
There's such a great comic book series
that revolves around Reed Richards and
Scott Lang, specifically Ant-Man's relationship.
I don't know how much of it you could fit into it,
but I don't know. That could be really fun. FF,
you ever read that?
I didn't read FF.
Terrific. Mike Allred and Matt Fraction's.
I remember hearing it.
Spectacular. So worth checking out-
Check that one out.
... if you ever get a chance.
I will. I do have a chance. I work for
Looper. That's all I do now.
It's our job.
We don't work. This is great.
No, we can read comics.
It's called research.
Cool, man.
Yeah.
That's my pick.
That's good.
That's a fantastic
idea. That works really, really well.
Thank you. Kevin, are you listening? I mean,
I'll still work for Looper, but maybe
we'll talk on the phone. I don't know.
Yeah. Shoot Brian a text, Kevin.
Because I assume he doesn't have any
of this figured out yet and he's just waiting
for someone cool like me to go on YouTube or
Facebook or wherever you're watching this
and talk about his ideas for the comic book
movies. I'm the only one who's ever done that.
He needs not sleeping at night.
He needs the assist. He's not getting by.
Yeah. You're welcome. You've been waiting for
someone just like me to do something
just like this. There's no one else
out there doing this. This is very unique.
It's a good thing we thought to talk about comic
books on the internet. This is going to be lost.
Yeah. Anyway, that's the end of that. Thanks for
joining us. Please hit like and subscribe
so you don't miss a single episode.